- What if the 15 year olds watch this
and they're like, yeah obviously
they're not going to do as well as us.
They're old.
(whistle blowing)
(cheerful music)
- My name is Clark and I'm kind
of active, but I hate gyms.
- In comparison to this dude right here,
I'm pretty athletic.
- In high school I did wrestling.
Wrestling was so intense,
so I quit wrestling and
joined musical theater.
- I'm pretty athletic.
I use to break dance.
- I use to be active when I was younger.
I played every sport you could think of.
- I think I am much more athletic
in my mind than I am in body.
- I try to go to the gym
like four days a week.
- Good, that's good.
- I think that's it, thank you.
(drum roll)
(sad music)
- Ah, crap, this is that flexibility test.
I sucked at this thing.
- Oh no, this is the
worst part of gym for me.
- [Interviewer] So today
ya'll will be retaking
the New York State physical fitness test.
(laughing)
- I just wanna do better
than the 15 year old girl.
- Um, it says an 11 year
old boy can do 47 curl ups.
What, I don't even think I can do 20.
(whistle blowing)
- Five, six.
- Seven, eight, you're goin'.
- Nine, 10, 11, 12.
- Oh my god, my boobs.
- 14, 15.
- It's about how hard you
can push and keep going!
That's how winning is done!
- 38, 39, 40.
- 55, 56, 57, 58.
You're as strong as a 12 year old boy.
- I did it!
- You did it man.
- You've got nothin' on me!
(dinging)
(buzzing)
- So, for an 11 year old
male, the goal is 26 push ups.
One, two three, two, two three.
- Three, two three.
- 12, two three.
- 13, ah come on, give me 14.
I hate this so much.
- 21, two three, 22, two three.
- 14, two three.
- Four, two...
(spitting)
- Come on push, give
me five, give me five.
Wow you weren't kidding.
- 31 man, that was close.
You did good, you almost
beat that 15 year old.
- I'm upset and disappointed in myself.
- Either you're gonna do worse than a kid
or you're gonna do better
than a kid, and it's like...
- Yeah, what are you,
gonna brag about that?
Walk out of here just like I
squashed those 12 year olds.
(dinging)
(buzzing)
- His whole upper body
is like my whole height.
You gotta make your legs
straight sir, no cheatin'.
- And so for females,
they have to go this far.
- What!
- Divin' in to two.
- No, that didn't go anywhere.
- What, 32, Jesus Christ!
(yelling)
Ah, didn't do it.
- 24, that is exactly 24.
- Yeah well I gotta for 31.
- Oh!
(yelling)
- I bumped that one.
(dinging)
(buzzing)
- I thought that I probably
would be able to perform
at an 11 year olds standard, but...
- Let's say there's my crush and
here I am trying to do push ups.
He's going to be disappointed at
the girl who couldn't do more than three.
- But if you're good at something
and it makes you happy, do it.
If that's sports, do it.
If it's not sports, that's okay.
It may not seem like it's okay right now,
but I promise you, you'll be
shocked at how okay it is.
- Spread body positivity, alright.
I was voted the most
athletic girl in high school
and look at me now,
look at me now, ya know.
So this could be you, so
don't talk to fast about
that person that can
only do five push ups.
He doesn't even have to take
a flexibility test anymore.
Look at this, this guy is a genius.
(yelling)
A 15 year could beat Eric, can you?
Can ya, can ya, can ya?